we were on the brain if you say that one
more time i'm gonna break up with you
while fans can often quote the legendary
sitcom many cast members don't actually
remember some major characters and
events
today we're diving into secrets from
behind the scenes and what the
experience was like for the cast of
friends
who unknowingly ate food and other
actors spit out on set
which musical performances has matt
leblanc reenacted since the series ended
don't you boys sneak a taste one of the
funniest moments of this thanksgiving
episode was rachel's valiant attempts at
making an english trifle
look at it isn't it beautiful the
shepherd's pie trifle mesh she wound up
making was
understandably revolting but ross being
ross went ahead and tried to shovel it
into his mouth
it tastes like feet i like it in an
interview
matt leblanc revealed that when ross
started laughing and they had to stop
leblanc generously took a bunch of the
food off of schwimmer's plate
what he hadn't noticed was the fact that
schwimmer had actually
spat out the food that he just put on
his plate and then proceeded to eat
what's worse is that no one said a thing
about it only after the fact at the wrap
party did leblanc discover what had
really happened when watching the
blooper reel
we're not entirely surprised this
happened it is pretty typical for joey
while their theme song i'll be there for
you is one of the most recognizable in
tv history
after all who watching this hasn't
perfected that signature clap
now while we all may love it the main
cast wasn't a fan
at all that's right the tune that was
literally their theme song was disliked
by the friends
now although aniston wasn't a big fan of
the song hearing it can still make her
emotional
a few years ago in an interview with
graham norton norton in the studio
audience surprised her with a specially
timed friend's reference
norton casually said no one told you
life is going to be this way
the audience was on it with those
friends claps you guys are
good this emotional moment wasn't a
total surprise though
in one interview her castmates revealed
that she was probably the most emotional
of the bunch and was often caught crying
whether it was during interviews or
emotional moments on set
i'll start crying it makes sense that
she was the last to leave the studio on
their last day of filming
i mean it's the end of an era i know
if any of us had to do friends trivia
against one of the cast members
we'd want it to be courtney cox who's
admitted that she's forgotten
a lot about the show and actually can't
remember some pretty major details
one of the worst lapses in her memory
was when she forgot who mike was
i'm a pretty nice guy not only that she
forgot paul rudd was the one
who played him and the fact that he and
phoebe got married
that's mike oh my god of course sorry
what makes it all worse is that she was
actually
there in their marriage scene although
we can't totally blame her
with 236 episodes to look back on we'd
probably forget some plot points too
but maybe not such major ones
matt leblanc had his fair share of
singing on the show and while that was
both hilarious
and impressive what's even more
incredible is that years later
he still remembers the lyrics during an
interview leblanc was questioned about
his musical talents on the show
remember when he was playing the lead in
the musical freud we've done some
excellent work here
how about when he created a song about
the man he met who had the same hands as
him
he was asked and he definitely delivered
this hand is my hand no wait that's your
hair
leblanc knew they were ridiculous tunes
which is probably part of the reason
they were so memorable
remember the one where chandler got
stuck in an atm vestibule with jill
goodaker
matthew perry does and he said it's
actually the episode where he knew the
show was really
special since he shot almost all of his
scenes with just good acre he got to
spend most of the episode watching his
fellow actors doing their thing and
really witnessed how it was affecting
audiences from then on he had no doubt
the show was a hit
it just felt like the right thing if
lisa kudrow were flipping through the
channels and friends came up
she would keep flipping i don't watch it
if it's on
so why exactly won't the phoebe watch
phoebe
she said it's because she worries she
won't like herself on the show so she
just avoids it completely
funny enough when she first read the
script kudrow related more to rachel
that being said she loved the experience
of doing the show and vividly remembers
just how thrilling doing that pilot was
anyone remember the one with the
blackout this was cox's favorite episode
because it was so fun to do
and watch so what was it like filming
according to courtney the cast and crew
were laughing pretty much the entire
time they were shooting
one of the gems of course being ross
being attacked by the cat
david schwimmer was not the biggest fan
of the moment himself
behind the scenes he was surprised for
how long it had to go on
their director james burrows had just
shouted keep going and
wouldn't cut just just said keep doing
it keep doing it until i
i yell cut everyone enjoyed it well
almost everyone for aniston the episode
she loved most was when she and ross got
so drunk they wound up getting married
in vegas because it was insanely fun to
shoot
besides that she always loved a good
throwback to when they were rachel
without the nose job
fat monica and ross with the fro since
it was such a shake up for them
it makes me happy how can we forget when
ross got hit with the puck at a hockey
game hey look we're on that tv thing
later in the episode we see ross and
joey in the hospital while ross is still
bandaged and as we see
joey mimicking getting hit in the head
with the puck over and over again
matt leblanc shared that this was a
spontaneous moment born when director
james burrows mimicked doing it
jimmy goes hey leblanc and i look up and
he goes
this kind of small direction was one of
the reasons the cast loved working with
burroughs so much
there were many times when that kind of
small suggestion was made and amped it
up to the comedy level that we know and
love
the cast didn't frequently watch
episodes they shot but during the first
season
they all used to get together and watch
the show and talk to each other about
their work
we really just wanted to hang out with
each other they would think of ideas for
each other and offer suggestions for
their characters and performances
actors giving other performers notes is
generally frowned upon but for this
group
it helped and was actually welcomed the
collaborative nature of the show
definitely contributes to the incredible
chemistry on screen
we can't imagine friends without
jennifer aniston and david schwimmer
but the fact is both of them almost
didn't do the show
aniston was on a show before doing
friends and the producer from that show
said friends wouldn't make her a star
obviously they were very wrong when
schwimmer got the call from his agent to
do the show
he actually turned it down i was like
i'm never doing another sitcom
and then legendary director james
burroughs told schwimmer he should come
down to meet everyone
of course he couldn't say no and i was
like i can't say no to this guy he's
like a legend
when he finally met the writers they let
him in on a secret
they had actually written the part for
him he knew pretty quickly to say yes
and are we
ever glad he did when they weren't
rachel monica and phoebe having a meal
together
they were jennifer courtney and lisa
having lunch
this really does put me in a better mood
every single day the ladies bonded
sharing lunch together
what did they eat a jennifer salad some
bonding on the boys side was a bit more
prank based
a special one was revealed by matt
leblanc who told the story of when he
put an i love friends license plate
frame on david schwimmer's car
who went a full week without noticing do
you remember that
did you yes that was me we all love to
have mementos from special times in our
lives
so it's no surprise the friends kept a
bunch of props from the show
like jennifer aniston who actually stole
one of monica's dresses from the show
and still
wears it and it fits or how about the
recognizable jewelry kudrow wears
those are authentic phoebe pieces in the
2021 reunion special
we heard from matthew perry that he
actually stole the cookie jar with the
clock on it from set and gifted it to
kudrow as well
one monumental moment for the cast was
when they renegotiated their contracts
together from early on in the series to
make sure that they were all paid
equally
they also made sure to fight to get
raises for themselves as the show grew
in popularity
that's great good for you guys the
question we've never stopped asking
were they or were they not on a break
well according to schwimmer
they were
in her famous instagram post aniston
responded to a comment saying that they
were still
on a break that's all the confirmation
we need
you and me all right this is it this is
it unless we're on a break
it's crazy to believe that friends ended
so many years ago while the characters
and lions remain so popular today
knowing about how close the cast
actually was and how they work together
only makes us love the show even more
which behind the scenes secret was your
favorite